you'll pay from Hyde Park on the Hudson a
different voice Franklin Roosevelt relaxes
with his wife and grandchildren at his ancestral
home out of this patrician background has come his
sweeping program of socials to reform a life
tops despite inherited wealth and privileged
position he is somehow acquired the common touch
that endears him to the common man a person and
inner buoyancy have smooth his path in politics
once he said to Orson Welles you and I are the
two best actors in America his second home is
Warm Springs Georgia where he finds relief in
the mineral waters infantile paralysis deprived
him of the use of his legs at the age of 39 the
President of the United States is the first man
in history to achieve world's stature without the
ability to walk his affliction says his wife
Eleanor and gave him strength and courage he
had not had before but though a [ __ ] he is no
envelope at Warm Springs he becomes dr. Roosevelt
and frolics fellow victims whom he calls my
gang we are going to make it a crusade says
Roosevelt on his campaign for re-election in
1936 though major New Deal measures like NRA
and triple-a have been declared unconstitutional
by the Supreme Court millions of men have been
put to work and the National Business Index
has almost doubled all across the land the
president is hailed as a gay crusader who has led
his nation out of the economic wilderness without
dictatorship or revolution to the many who feel
that happy days are here again is FDR the Channel